gattaz tout-puissant merci pour une
brunoise séparation entre le medef et
l'état une bonne grève ça se prépare
mercredi travailleurs chômeurs mais
aussi étudiants descendront dans la rue
pour manifester contre le projet de
réforme du code du travail à lui vs q
les membres de l'union nationale des
étudiants de france préparent déjà leur
arsenal
il faut montrer qu'on a aussi des idées
ou des arguments de poids qu'on sait de
quoi on parle qu'on n'est pas juste
voilà des petits jeunes qui sommes là
dans la rue pour protester parce que
c'est cool de pas aller en cours mais
qu'on a vraiment des arguments qu'on a
vraiment des convictions derrière tout
ça
le fait que ce soit une grève générale
avec l'ensemble des travailleurs des
chômeurs des étudiants des lycéens qui
sont appelés à faire grève c'est
seulement de cette façon là qu'on peut
avoir un rapport de force suffisant pour
changer quelque chose
un rapport de force numérique après la
pétition internet qui comptabilise déjà
plus d'un million de signatures
le gouvernement sera attentif à la
mobilisation de demain
l'unef s'oppose à toute négociation
aujourd'hui silva possible et même au
delà de ça quand on nous dit que le
projet loi a été reculée nous ça ne
suffit pas on a envie et on veut du coup
obligatoirement un retrait du projet un
retrait demandé par l'ensemble des
syndicats étudiants comme un
arrière-goût de cpe demain le mouvement
des jeunes socialistes l'union des
étudiants communistes et d'autres
syndicats étudiants rejoindront l'unef
pour un départ à 11 heures vers paris
place de la république